there are many things you have to
overcome first the language then if
you're Portuguese the climate then the
way people are and of course the weather
it took me years to acclimatize Fernando
Maeda was born in northern Portugal in
1977 he grew up in Lisbon the capital
after finishing school he trained as a
cook he owes his passion for good food
to his mother as a child he watched how
she cooked fernando moved to berlin when
he was 21 working in various restaurants
and as a DJ on the side until he opened
his lisboa bar in 2010 then increasing
Lisbon has a huge market where you can
buy everything I was a child it
fascinated me to walk through the market
and see the contrasting colors and
fruits fish and meat how is that done
how is it prepared the market always
fired my curiosity Portuguese cuisine is
relatively unknown in Germany and
Fernando Almeida wants to change that
his emphasis is on the small dishes
there Pettis cos they're served as
appetizers much like the Spanish tapas
an imported all they're part of every
meal
all the wines served in this restaurant
come from Portugal in Portugal people
eat a lot when I go home to visit my mom
she sees me taking a small plate of food
and says son your starve to death you
have to eat something
- phone was the most processing it's
Maricopa in Durham and I see it with
other people
the Portuguese spend a quarter of their
earnings on food sometimes more than 1/4
VN s envisioned Tata planner Mara Terra
which translates as sea and earth is a
Portuguese steer that comes in many
variations the recipe originated in
southern Portugal the dish is named
after the pot it's prepared in the cotta
planner
[Music]
the Portuguese have been cooking in this
copper pot since the 8th century
it's especially suited for gently
preparing foods because when the lid is
on the food is steamed that preserves
the flavor of the individual ingredients
a Portuguese cuisine is very varied on
the coast people traditionally eat a lot
of fish in the interior more meat comes
to the table what's special about Casa
planner Mara Tara is that all the
ingredients cooked together with the
meat even the seafood
[Music]
this is a typical Portuguese dish very
special you mix the meat and the fish
fish they're cool I don't know why but I
do know that the Portuguese are always
ready to try new things
just like in seafaring the Portuguese
were always willing to discover new land
even though the dangers were great at
sea unchanged Portuguese culture this is
shrunk low-vision in the Portuguese
occult worker picked
Fernando spent three months renovating
the rooms of what had been a store and
even built some of the furniture himself
he wanted a rustic ambience like in a
country inn in Portugal his small
restaurant has room for 35 guests
many come specifically for Fernando's
homemade pastel Donata
a traditional pudding tartlet
the lesbo bar is located on box Wagner
plots in Cleveland district it's the
only Portuguese restaurant in this
district which is home to many young
people of students and families it
McKenna through this I really like
Frederick size there's a certain freedom
here people do what they want it's still
very much an alternative neighborhood
not so she she and I really like the mix
of people that come here he's a chemist
is public you all get fed Mia Phyllis
Baba has many regular guests from the
neighborhood they like the private
atmosphere and when Fernando Armada has
time he brings the food to the table
himself
hola Yokozuna Provo scissors cutter
planner Morita spirit and estado bought
it